it's the start of a make-or-break week
for the business and that means getting
my prisoners up at the crack of dawn
shall we
with bustling Brixton town centre on the
doorstep today we're trying a lunch
delivery service to save the public have
the appetite for prison made sandwiches
we have to be better than the
competition yeah this is not just a
ploughman's and a [ __ ] soggy sandwich if
we're gonna make a rap let me tell you
it's gonna be the best [ __ ] rap
that's get prepped if the lunches sell
well my plan is to start producing them
five days a week on the menu
handmade wraps and sandwiches with the
choice of freshly prepared speciality
fillings yeah moist delicious roasted
red pepper hummus roller in the
seasoning try and keep it on either side
and a free-range british favorite simple
cheap and cheerful Scotch shake please
getting 250 lunches out before 11 a.m.
requires efficient teamwork my concern
is not all of this lot are up to it I
never thought the wedding is the globe
I mean they have to learn to change year
like in any job but I mean talk about
changing gear look at norm he's been
stuck in [ __ ] neuticle 25 years
convicted thief has an or is only 23
but he's already do his third prison
stretch twins
are you going else oh yeah how old when
you had them
okay now 14
that's [ __ ] young 14 where are the
kids now was that three kids five kids
we never had our condo 23 I've got five
kids straightaway
[ __ ] you get labeled straightaway in
it so I'm really happy that my mom a dad
my sister
they think I'm a [ __ ] I kind of
respect how people think that is all but
yeah just gonna leave the faucet there
if I wanted that car and money is the
issue if it means me same enjoy them I
can buy it then I'd suck to make sure
don't get arrested
that's I used to think for their guys 15
minutes I'm out of here okay
I'm not afraid of a challenge but I've
got my hands full with us an
affectionate
you know do it properly they look like
doing that well they get me now
hopefully I don't get you
that's just there I'm gonna make it my
own personal mission to try and turn
house an into a productive team member
the first ever batch of bad boys bakery
lunches are ready to go a little slogan
bad boy bacon in that key in case even
has hands not dumb enough to be
smuggling stuff out but rules are rules
every sandwich wrap and Scotch egg has
to be scanned
[Music]
see that guy's banged up in here these
guys are no good as delivery workers so
it's left up to me to do the rounds jump
in the box jump in the box it's nearly
midday I'm in danger of missing the
lunchtime trade party night where
[Music]
keep it going keep it going as usual
getting anything done in a hurry is
impossible it's been activated sir thank
you
is a dog working thank God for that
finally I've broken out now I've got to
flog the goods to a skeptical public
it's gonna be a difficult sell however
riding the product is good I'm hoping
that an over question who made it